[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم في تطورات الازمه
السياسيه الحاليه في العراق اعطى نور
المالكي مهله تنتهي الثلاثاء لوزراء
التيار الصدري المقاطعين
لجلسات الحكومه مهله لانهاء مقاطعتهم هذه
نتوقف اذا مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين المحور الاول حول مدى قدره المالك
على الامساك بزمام الامور في ضوء تصاعد
حجم الخلافات مع خصومه السياسيين ثم هل
يصل خلاف التيار الصدري مع رئيس الحكومه
الى حد تجاوز الاراده الايرانيه الداعمه
للمالك
يواجه اذا رئيس الحكومه العراقيه نور
المالكي موجه من الاحتجاجات ضد سياساته
خرجت من الغرف المغلقه الى رحاب الشارع في
صوره تظاهرات واعتصامات في مدن عده وكما
يحاول المالك استخدام كل الوسائل لاحتواء
معارضيه والحفاظ على منصبه يسعى خصوص
ايضا للضغط عليه في اطار الصراع السياسي
متعدد الاطراف في
العراق جاء يتفقد عن كثب عراقا انهكته
انقسامات نخبه السياسيه كان لابد لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه جون كيري ان يلتقي نور
المالكي رئيس الوزراء الذي اشتد الجدل في
بلاد الرافدين حول سياسات حكومته وبات
خصومه لا يرون حلا لمشاكل البلاد سوى
رحيله يدرك كيري ان معارضي المالك اخفق
سابقا في اسقاطه بسحب الثقه منه برلمانيا
فحاول ان يطرح افكارا لحل حله الوضع بعد
ان استمع للشكاوى السنه على لسان رئيس
البرلمان اسامه النجيفي عارفا في نفس
الوقت ان صبر الجماهير الغاضبه على
المالكي لا يمكن ان يستمر الى ما لا نهايه
مع احساسها بانه لا يقدر دقه المرحله التي
تمر بها البلاد راوح المالكي بين الشده
واللين في الطاعات مع الازمه القائمه في
بلاده ولوح تجاه الفاعلين السياسيين
بالعصا والجزاره في كل مره احس منهم العزم
على ازاحته وهو الامر الذي بدا جليا في
ظاهره تعليق وزراء الكتل الغاضبه مشاركتهم
في جلسات الحكومه ثم عوده بعضهم عن هذا
القرار في ظل وعود بالوصول الى توافقات لا
يجوع فيها الذئب ولا يشتكي منها الراعي
منهج صنع خارطه متقلبه التحالفات فهاهم
وزراء القيادي في القائمه العراقيه صالح
المطلق يعودون الى سالف نشاطهم الحكومي في
حين بقي وزراء التيار الصدري على ذمه مهله
من المالك لثنيهم عن تعليق عملهم في
الحكومه موقف يتجاوز في نظر التيار الصدري
العمل ضمن الفريق الحكومي الى رفض لما قال
الصدريون انها سياسه ممنهجه لتهميش السنه
وهو الموقف الذي ظل في نظر البعض محكوما
بسقف اقليمي ايراني لا يرى مصلحته في
تنحيه المالك في المرحله الراهنه سقف
سيكون في القلب من عمل لجنه كرديه شكلت
مؤخرا لتخوض نقاشا موسعا مع باقي مكونات
الساحه السياسيه حول بند حصري توحيد
المواقف من مساله الانسحاب من حكومه
المالك وليس فقط تعليق المشاركه
فيها موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه اذا مع
الكتور عدنان السراج عضو ائتلاف دوله
القانون بزعمه المالك
وسوف طبعا هو معنا من بغداد وسوف ينضم
الينا من
بيروت بعد قليل الدكتور ضياء الاسدي
الامين العام لكتله الاحرار التابعه
للتيار الصدري نرحب بك اذا دكتور عدنان
السراج في انتظار التحاق ضيفنا من بيروت
ونبدا معك اذا بالحديث حول المسؤوليه
السياسيه لرئيس الوزراء نوري المالكي
باعتباره طبعا رئيسا للحكومه مسؤوليته عن
هذه الازمه السياسيه التي تعيشها او
يعيشها العراق ما مدى قدره المالكي دكتور
عدنان على الامساك بزمام الامور اليوم في
ضوء هذه التفاعلات الخطيره للازمه
السياسيه في
العراق نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لعل
السؤال فيه درجه من الاحراج وفي درجه من
الدقه للاجابه عليه ولعل الاجابه عندما
تاتي نجد بعض الفرقاء يجدون في في هذه
الاجابه يعني توجيه السهام الى الاليات
والتقاطعات اللي تقوم بها الكتل السياسيه
انا اقول ومن خلال التحليل السياسي
الواقعي ان النور المالكي ضروره عراقيه في
هذه المرحله وهذه المرحله التي لم يبقى
امامها الا سنه وشهران من اجل اجراء
انتخابات برلمانيه فهو اصبح ضروره محليه
وضروره اقليميه وضروره دوليه وت ما وجه
الضروره دكتور عدنان دعنا نفهم هذه النقطه
معك يعني ما وجه الضروره في بقاء رئيس
وزراء يحتج عليه كثيرون وتشهد مناطق كثيره
في العراق احتجاجات واعتصامات تدخل يعني
قريبا شهرها
الرابع لعده اسباب السبب الاول نوري
المالكي الوحيد الذي مسك العراق من شماله
الى جنوبه مع الخلافات السياسيه في وحدته
اي بمعنى استطاع من اخراج الامريكان بقوه
سياسته وايضا باعتراف الدول الاقليميه
والدول العالميه وحتى امريكا والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هو لحد هذه الدقيقه
يحظى باتفاق محلي ودولي وحتتى اممي
وبالتالي نجد ان العراق في حاجه الى رجل
محبوب شعبيا ولا زالت شعبيته تسجل تقدم مع
كل ازمه انا اقول ذلك نعم نور الملكي
محبوب شعبيا دكتور عدنان نعم نور المالكي
محبوب شعبيا نعم لديه امكان ا نعم محبوب
شعبيا والدليل على ذلك هو عندما يريد ان
يحل برلمان ويج انتخابات مبكره الكتل التي
تخاف على شعبيتها لا تقبل بذلك هو يريد
ونحن نريد في دوله
القانون انتخبات جديده واعاده الك نعم
دكتور عدنان يعني مهم ان نفهم معك ما يجري
في العراق تقول نوري المالكي مطلوب وهو
ضروره اليوم ضروره محليه وضروره اقليميه
وضروره دوليه وانه محبوب شعبيا كيف نسمي
هذه الاحتجاجات بالالاف في عده مدن عراقيه
كيف نسمي
انسحاب حوالي 17 وزير
من حكومه نوري المالكي مات تسمي كل
هذا الانسحاب في القاموس السياسي غير
موجود هناك تعليق للمشاركه وهناك تعليق
بانواع اخرى هو يداوم في الوزاره ولكنه لا
يشترك في مجلس الوزراء التعليق غير
الانسحاب التيار الصدري لديه افكار واراء
معينه وطنيه قد يجد في حاله حلها مثلا
قضيه الانبار ونينو اذا حلت
علها التيار الصدري لاكثر من مره اما
القائمه العراقيه فغدا ستشهد رجوع اغلب
الوزراء القائمه العراقيه ما عدا السيد
العيساوي فقط اما الاكراد فهم علقوا
واليوم وبعد غد لديهم اجتماعات مهمه من
اجل وانا اعتقد في تقديري الاكراد
يحسبونها جيدا وهم عندما سمعوا الراي
الامريكي فهم سوف يعودون باسرع ما يمكن
الى الحكومه وسوف تترتب الامور من جديد
بشكل انفراج هذا رايي واعتقد رايي مستند
على ما اسمعه وما اشاهده في دوله القانون
وفي لقاءاتنا مع المسؤولين في هذا الاتجاه
اما بالنسبه لما نقول تفضل تفضل
تفضل اما بالنسبه ليما اقول ان نور المالك
ضروره اختي العزيزه سحب الثقه لاقوى كتل
سياسيه لم تنجح ومحاولات الاجتماعات
الاخرى لن تنجح نور المالكي لن يقود
ميليشيات بالمطلق لم يدخل في دم السني ولا
الشيعي ولا اي انسان انما دخل في مساجله
من اجل بناء الدوله انا هنا لا اريد ان
ادافع عن شخص انسان انا ادافع عن حاله
لرئيس وزراء العراق فقط يعني الذ المسم
حتىلا اك لا لا نعتبره دفاعا ولكن الالاف
المؤلفه التي تخرج كل يوم في عدد كبير من
المدن العراقيه للاحتجاج على سياسات
المالكي كيف تراها
انت ارا من خلال خطاب السيد المالكي اليوم
عندما اشاد بهيئه الراي لشيوخ الانبار
عندما شكلوا وفدا برئاسه نجل السيد السعدي
لمقابله الحكومه واجراء مفاوضات واستقبال
وفد الحكومه هو اشاد بهذه المبادره
واعتبرها مبادره سلميه انا مع هذا الاتجاه
مع اتجاه انه السيد المالكي نعم مع
السلميه مع مظاهرات تؤدي الى حقوق الناس
وبالمناسبه انا سمعت للاكثر من مره داخل
دوله القانون ومن خلال رئيس الوزراء سمعت
اكثر من مره ان المظاهرات قد افرزت شيئا
جديدا حيث حرمت الدم السني والشيعي
بالمطلق المرجع الشيعي يحرم الدم السني
وعلماء السنه يحرمون الدم السني وهذا الدم
الشيعي وهذا دليل على ان العراق من خلال
هذه المظاهرات اثبت شيء واضح جدا يمكن ان
تكون مظاهرات مطلب ويمكن ان تكون وحده
العراق ايضا هي الهدف من اجل ان نحقق تلك
المكاسب وهذا شيء جيد انا في تقديري طيب
يعني الوضع القانوني الان لحكومه نوري
المالكي في ظل عدم وجود نحو 17 وزيرا اليس
وضعا هل تراه انت وضعا سليما الوضع
القانوني
للحكومه لا بالعكس انا لا اعتبره وضعا
سليما ولكنه انا اعتبر هذا التصرف هو تصرف
غير مسؤول التصرف الغير مسؤ الحكومه ما
ذنبها المواطنون ما ذنبهم اذا لدي خلافات
سياسيه فعلي ان اذهب الى الكتل السياسيه
اذهب الى مجلس النواب من اجل سحب الثقه
اما ان يؤثر على الحكومه بهذه الطريقه انا
اريد اناقش قضيه مهمه ما دام فسح لي الوقت
الان الانسحابات ماذا تعني اسقاط الحكومه
لا تستطيع الكتل السياسيه من اسقاط
الحكومه وانا اقول كذلك هناك خطوط حمر
محليه واقليميه ودوليه واميه هذه الخطوط
الحمر هل هي خطوط حمراء هل هي خطوط حمراء
ايرانيه مثلا من يضع هذه الخطوط ايرانيه
ايرانيه وامريكيه وعربيه وامم والامين
العام للامم المتحده وكل دول العالم
السانده للمشروع الديمقراطيه في العراق
هذا هذه اراده ليس اراده دوله واحده الان
تشاهدين كثير من الدول اصبحت التدخلات في
شؤونها شيء طبيعي كما يحصل في سوريا وكما
يحصل في ليبيا وفي مصر وفي كل بلدان
العالم اصبحت القضيه الاقليميه تلعب دور
مهم الحلقه الاقليميه زائدا الحلقه
الدوليه اصبحت شيء مهم في تاريخ او في
سياسه البلدان العربيه نعم اذا كنا نتحدث
عن البعد الدولي وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ابلغ رئيس الوزراء نوري المالكي امتعاضا
امريكيا من سياسات المالكي وطالبه باجراء
انتخابات في المحافظات التي اجلت فيها هذه
الانتخابات كيف ترى
ذلك انا لا انا مطلع اطلاع كامل على ما
جرى بين السيد وزير الخارجيه والسيد رئيس
الوزراء لم يكن ممتعضا على العكس من ذلك
اشاد بجهود الحكومه الوطنيه اشاد بتقدم
الديمقراطيه الا انه اعترض على شيء انه
مساله الطيران الايراني الى سوريا والعراق
بلسان السيد المالك اخبره بان كل الطائرات
التي تعبر الاجواء العراقيه تجري عليها
مراقبه مشدده وايضا مساله اعاده اعاده
النظر في انتخابات الانبار وال نينوى
وابلغه السيد المالكي نحن مع مصلحه
الانباري واهل نينوى من اجل ان تكون
انتخابات نزيهه وواقعيه والقضيه محصوره في
مجلس الوزراء والمفوضين اليا للانتخابات
ايه سنواصل اذا النقاش في هذه النقطه ولكن
بعد الفاصل بعد فاصل قصير س نناقش بعده هل
يتجاوز
سقف خلاف الصدريين مع نوري المالكي هل
يتجاوز حدود الدعم الايراني له لكن نرجو
ان تبقوا معنا لاننا بعد الفاصل ايضا
سينضم الينا ضيفنا الثاني انضم الينا
الدكتور ضياء الاسدي وهو الامين العام
لكثره الاحرار التابعه للتيار الصدري اذا
نعود لنقاش هذا مع ضيفين ولكن بعد فاصل
قصير مشاهدينا لا تذهبوا
بعيدا مشاهدينا اهلا بكم من جديد الى
حلقتنا هذه التي تناقش الخلافه السياسيه
بين المالك والتيار الصدري في العراق
وينضم الينا اذا في هذا الجزء الثاني من
البرنامج الدكتور ضياء الاسدي الامين
العام لكتله الاحرار التابعه للتيار
الصدري دكتور ضياء الاسدي ربما تابعت معنا
الجزء الاول من هذا البرنامج وقد تحدثنا
فيه في البدايه عن انسحاب الصدريين من
الحكومه العراقيه
طبعا المالكي امه لكم يومين انتهى يوم بقي
يوم للعوده الى اجتماعات الحكومه هل
ستعودون بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الرحيم
تحيه لكم وللضيف الكريم
ولمشاهده الاحرار الوزراء فقط علقوا
حضورهم في اجتماعات مجلس الوزراء ولكنهم
ما زالوا يؤدون اعمالهم يعني بشكل مهني في
وزاراتهم يقدمون الخدمات يؤدون اعمالهم
اليوميه ا اعضاء مجلس النواب عن كتله
الاحرار ما زالوا مستمرين في حض جلسات
مجلس النواب لم يعلقوا حضورهم اذا من
الناحيه العمليه الصدريين ما زالوا
مشاركين في الحكومه ويعملون بشكل فايق ما
اسباب التعليق دكتور نعم اسباب التعليق
كان هناك مجموعه من التراكمات ولكن السبب
الاساسي هو
عرض قانون او عرض مساله تاجيل انتخابات
محافظتي الانبار والموصل بشكل طارئ على
جدول اعمال مجلس الوزراء اولا هذا الموضوع
هو ليس من تخصص مجلس الوزراء هذا الموضوع
هو من تخصص القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
والمفوض العليا المشرفه على الانتخابات
السبب الذي دعا الى التصويت على هذا
القرار هو ان هناك تقارير امنيه تفيد بعدم
امكانيه اجراء الانتخابات في هاتين
المحافظتين لاسباب امنيه بدون الرجوع طبعا
الى راي المفوضيه العليا المشرفه على
الانتخابات لانها في الوقت الذي صوت في
على هذا القرار كانت المفوضيه تناقش
الاجراءات اللوجستيه المتبقيه ل انتخابات
المقبله اذا هذا القرار اتخذ بشكل ارتجالي
يعني لدينا معطيات ولدينا وثائق تثبت بان
القرار عرض بشكل سريع وطارئ واتخذ بشكل
طارئ القرار فيما يتعلق بتاجيل الانتخابات
في الانبار ونينه ومازال قائما هل تعليق
الوزراء سيبقى قائما ام كيف ستردون على
المهله نعم نعم تعليق وزراء كتله الاحرار
سيبقى قائما لن يحضروا اجتماعات مجلس
الوزراء الا ان يلغى هذا القرار اليوم
للمفارق السيد رئيس مجلس الوزراء يقول ان
هذا القرار هو ليس من صلاحيات القائد
العام للقوات المسلحه هو من صلاحيات مجلس
الوزراء ولكن عندما عرض القرار على
الوزراء قال لهم وكل الوزراء موجودون
كانوا موجود موجودين في في مجلس الوزراء
قال لهم بان هذا القرار هو من صلاحيات
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه وليس من
صلاحيات مجلس الوزراء لا ندري حقيقه يعني
ما هو الموقف موقف الحكومه لكننا من
الناحيه ال قانونيه ومن الناحيه الاداريه
نفهم بان يحق للقائد العام للقوات المسلحه
ان يتخذ مثل هذا القرار بناء على دراسه
مسبقه على تقارير واضحه تفيد بان اجراء
الانتخابات قضيه صعبه لكن هذه التقارير لم
تكن موجوده كل ما عرض على مجلس الوزراء هو
صفحه فيها سطرين يعني يشيران الى ان الوضع
الامني في الانبار والموصل لا يشجع على
اجراء
الانتخابات عد هذا او عدت هذه الصفحه
تقريرا امنيا واتخذ القرار على هذا الاساس
والوزراء عندما صوتوا كانوا يعتقدون ان
هناك تقارير امنيه وهناك وثائق وهناك
دراسه لكن الحال ان القرار طالما بقي
القرار بقي
التعليق بالتاكيد طالما بقي القرار لان
هذا القرار نحن لا نتحدث عن قرار فقط
نتحدث عن اراده جزء مهم من العراق اراده
جماهير في الموصل والانبار ثانيا نتحدث عن
شركاء في العمليه السياسيه مثل هذه
القرارات لا يمكن ان تتخذ من قبل حتى وان
كان مع كل الاحترام لمنصب القائد العام
للقوات المسلحه يجب ان تتخذ بالتشاور مع
الشركاء الاخرين طيب دع دعنا ناخذ راي
دكتور دكتور عدنان السراج في هذا في هذه
النقطه التعليق مستمر طالما بقيت اسبابه
مستمره ما
رايك يعني مثل ما انا تفضلت في المره
الاولى قلت انه الانسحاب ليس وارد انما هو
تعليق والتعليق لقضايا تعودنا التيار
الصدري انه لديه مواقف وهذه المواقف هو
رايه وهذا موقف وطني ويستطيع من خلال نكن
ولكن ايضا تعليق دكتور عدنان يعني هذا
التعليق لديه له اسبابه يعني هذا دليل
احتجاج على سياسات المالكي اليس
كذلك انا بالنسبه الي مثل ما هو راي هنا
ايضا راي هناك هناك راي يقول ان مساله
اجراء الانتخابات في هذه الظروف سوف يؤثر
على نزاهه الانتخابات وعلى نتائج
الانتخابات وبالتالي هناك من يحسبها بهذا
النوع وهناك من يحسبها بالاتجاه الاخر
المهم ان انه نستند الى القانون والدستور
ولكن انا احتجاجي الوحيد مساله الانسحاب
او تعليق العمل في الحكومه لا يشكل ضغطا
سياسيا بالمره لانه الانسحاب من الحكومه
او تعليق الحكومه ما الهدف منها مضايقه
نوري المالكي شخصيا ام مضايقه الشعب
العراقي شخص
عموما كلامك موجه مباشره لدكتور ضياء الاس
مو بس ضيا
ويحب من الحكومه العراقيه ك لم لمن يعلقون
مشاركتهم في الحكومه ومنهم الصدريون ومعنا
الدكتور ضياء الاسدي اذا يعني حركه لا
يعني او خطوه لا معنى لها يقول او هكذا
يريد ان يقول الدكتور عدنان السراج ما
الفائده من تعليق عضويه في حكومه لا يمكن
ان تضايق بالمصطلح الذي استعمله الدكتور
سراج لا تضايق ابدا نوري
المالكي سيدتي يعني الدكتور عدنان السراج
يعرف تماما ان نشوء توريات في المنطقه
تطورت بسبب سكوت المشاركين في العمل
السياسي بسبب سكوت الشعوب بسبب غض النظر
عن قرارات ترتجل في بعض المراحل تتطور من
خلالها الحكومات من حكومات تدعي تمثيلها
للشعب الى حكومات دكتاتوريه اذا سكت اذا
سكتنا عن قرارات تتخذ بهذه الطريقه فنعتقد
باننا سنكون مقصرين امام شعبنا وامام
جماهيرنا التي نمث ولكن خطوه قد لا تكون
دكتور اسدي ربما هذه خطوه ليست ذات اهميه
كبيره
يعني هناك من تجد من يقول لكم اما ان
تقرروا البقاء في الحكومه واما ان تستقيل
يعني هذا موقف رمادي بين هذا وذاك لماذا
لا تستقيل
اذا لا نستقيل لاننا نعبر عن جزء كبير من
الشعب العراقي له طموحاته وله تطلعاته وله
وله احتياجاته نحن نمثل شريحه كبيره لذلك
علينا ان
نلبي احتياجات وتطلعات هذه الشريحه
الكبيره من الشعب العراقي لا نريد ان نسلم
زمام الحكم الى اي جهه او طرف تقود البلد
الى ما لا يحمد عقباه تقود البلد الى
الدمار يعني الى اي مدى تجاوزنا قبل دكتور
دكتور الاسدي الى اي مدى يعني ارجو اجابه
صريحه ومباشره الى اي مدى يمكن للصدريين
الخروج عن الاراده الايرانيه بدعم
المالكي الصدريين طالما خرجوا عن ال اراده
الايرانيه يعني اتخذوا مواقف هي بعكس
الاراده الايرانيه الصدريون لا ينتظروا
املاءات من اي دوله من دول الجوار مع كل
الاحترام والتقدير للجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه ما يحفظ للعراق مصالحه هو ان
يكون هناك صانعو سياسه يكون هناك متخذين
للقرار يعتمدون على مصالح العراق الوطنيه
وليس على مصالح دول الجوار الصدريين لا
يريدون لاي جهه خارج العراق ان تؤثر على
القرار العراقي حتى وان كانت ايران وحتى
وان كانت اي دوله اخرى ترتبط بمصالح
جوهريه ومهمه مع العراقيين لذلك في صنع
السياسات نحن لا نعتمد بالدرجه الاساس على
المصلحه الايرانيه او الاراده الايرانيه
نحن نعتمد على مصلحه العراقيين واراده
العراقيين وهناك مواقف كثيره خرج فيها
سماحه السيد مقتضى الصدر عن التوافق
الايراني والتوافق التوافق بين ايران اقصد
والتوافق بين اطراف في الحكومه العراقيه
وليست الاطراف هذه شيعيه فقط بل حتى هناك
اطراف سنيه اتخذت مواقف تنسجم مع الاراده
الايرانيه وهناك اطراف من التحالف
الكردستاني ايضا اتخذت مواقف تنسجم مع
الاراده الايرانيه وكان الصدريون فقط
وصدري حسب هم الذين اتخذوا موقف مخالف
لهذه الارادات نعم لانهم يعتقدون الضياع
الاسدي يمكن يعني اريد ان اعطيك الوقت
لانك لم تكن معنا في الجزء الاول من
البرنامج لكن كل هذا الكلام يمكن ان يكون
مفهوما في انكم تتحدون الاراده الايرانيه
في دعم نوري المالكي لو ان مواقفكم انتم
الصدريين مواقف ثابته ولكن كثيرون يعاتبون
على مواقفكم المتقلبه ان صح التعبير مثل
موقفكم من قضيه سحب الثقه عن المالك ثم
تراجع بسحب وزرائهم مع وزراء قائمه
العراقيه بل وموافقتهم ايضا على تولي احد
وزرائهم وزاره الماليه بالوكاله قبل ان
يعلن وزيرها رافع العساوي استقالته كيف
ترد على مثل هذا الكلام ارجو ارجو ان
تعطيني الوقت الكافي ليوضح هذه الامور
لانها امور جوهريه
واساسيه فيما يتعلق بوزاره الماليه قبلنا
بتولي حقيبه وزاره الماليه وكاله لانه
خلاف ذلك لن تعمل وزاره من الوزارات
العراقيه التخصيصات الماليه تذهب من من
وزاره الماليه الى الوزارات الاخرى اذا
تعطلت وزاره الماليه فلن تعمل اي وزاره
اخرى لذلك قبلنا بهذه الوزاره وكاله ولم
نقبل بوزارات اخرى عرضت وكاله لذلك
فالقضيب تعتمد على مصلحه العراق وليس على
مصلح خاصه بال بالخط الصدري القضيه الاخرى
ان الصدريين قد يبدو على انهم متناقضين في
مواقفهم هذا هو ليس تناقض هذه الديناميكيه
السياسيه مساله سحب الثقه كنا وما زلنا
وقالها سماحه السيد مقتضى الصدر وقالها
قاده الخط الصدري اننا كنا مع سحب الثقه
عن طريق الاليات الدستوريه وكانت اهم
واسهل وابسط
الطرق من هذه الاليات هي ان يرسل او يخاطب
فخامه رئيس الجمهوريه مجلس النواب العراقي
يطالبه بعقد اجتماع طارئ ويصوتون على سحب
الثقه الصدريون فقط كانوا جاهزون لديهم 40
صوتا وضعوها تحت تصرف الشركاء ولكن للاسف
الشديد الشركاء الاخرين لم يفلحوا في جمع
امرهم او جمع اصواتهم ليقدموه بهذا
الصدد لجوا الى طريق اخر وهو طريق استجواب
رئيس الوزراء قلنا نحن ندعم في اللحظه
التي سيتم فيها التصويت في مجلس النواب
سندعم هذا التصويت لكن لم يبادروا هم
الشركاء الاخرين لم يبادروا الى التصويت
او اعداد الملف لذلك نحن لم نتقلب في
مواقفنا ابدا كنا وما زلنا مصرين على نفس
المبدا الذي كنا تبنينا في بدايه العمل
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور ضياء الاسدي
الامين العام لكتله الاحرار التابعه
للتيار الصدري نشكر ايضا من بغداد الدكتور
عدنان السراج عضو ائتلاف دوله القانون
بزعمه نوري المالكي كنت معنا من بغداد
شكرا لضيفنا اذا وشكرا لكم انتم مشاهدينا
على حسن المتابعه لكم منا اطيب المنى
والسلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم